with Nick I was madly in love it fell
out pretty quick Jessica Simpson's
memoir open book just hit shelves and it
is freaking stacked with bombshell
revelations now we're breaking down the
sixth wildest things we learned from the
singer's tell-all starting with this
they were gentlemen they did make every
day on set an absolute blast I I could
just stand over in the corner and laugh
at both of them with all their you know
one-liners
Jessica admits to having an emotional
affair with her Dukes of Hazzard co-star
Johnny Knoxville while she was still
married to Nick Lachey at the time
Johnny was married to we were open about
the challenges of our marriages and why
we felt we had to honor those vows by
sticking with the marriage she added
that she and Johnny would write love
letters back and forth often at night
with Nick passed out in bed next to her
she compares her in Johnny's
relationship to that of Prison pen pals
two people who wanted so much to be with
each other but were kept apart by bars
by our stars by our respective spouses
et has a full interview with Jessica
about the book dropping Tuesday night
and in it she opens up about her
marriage to the 98° singer with Nick I
was madly in love I mean I loved
everything about the guy and I wanted to
spend the rest of my life with him
Jessica and Nick called it quits in 2005
I was you know 22 years old when we got
married but you know I thought I knew my
future and I thought he was gonna be in
it forever I thought my dad was
completely wrong I was like no I got
this figured out watch you know like
I'll prove you wrong and she admits
things got ugly after he dropped his
music video for what's left of me
[Music]
to me
quote he'd recreated our life for the
video casting his future wife Vanessa
Minnillo to play me as this cold
unfeeling person I knew he did this to
hurt me just says she asked Nick to come
over and he did bringing his album which
featured a ton of songs about her to
play then they had sex one last time I
could feel his hate when he walked out
the door I knew I would never see him
again
moving on to her other public
relationships jessica says that her ex
John Mayer caused her breakup with Tony
Romo the songs that he would write I
mean they would bring me back it in his
apologies would bring me back in when
Tony saw an email come through from John
talking about being at her parents house
he assumed the worst he accused me of
seeing John behind his back
I hadn't cheated on Tony at all but I
could not lie and say I hadn't even seen
him he broke up with me right there two
years gone with an email and remember
those mom jeans the ones that had
everyone talking about Jessica's weight
in 2009 well they were a size four
people quote I had no idea I was about
to become a global joke the fact that I
was that skinny and that I was deemed
overweight still frightens me Jess also
reveals she had two tummy tucks in 2015
the tummy tucks were back to back that
was after I had lost a ton away yeah and
I had skin and like stretch marks
because I had to baby back to back
that's running months apart and one
being a nine-pounder almost ten pounder
and was hospitalized after she got an
infection the surgery took two hours
longer than planned it did not go well I
got an infection they had to rush me to
Cedars and I secretly stayed there for
nine days doctors talked seriously about
me needing a blood transfusion and the
bombshell to end all bombshells
she turned down the lead role in the
notebook
Hubert on the moon yeah Jess was up for
the role of ally but said no when they
wouldn't take out the sex scene with
Ryan Gosling
open book is on stands now as is the
audiobook which was apparently an
intense experience to record the audio
book is an amazing experience it was
extremely hard and emotional for me to
do I did it in five days and I didn't
realize how intense it would be when I
was reading everything it was it I mean
I liked throughout the audiobook you'll
hear me like I'm very emotional I cry
and I have to you know and you'll
probably cry with me or if you like wow
she's crying over that you know like
there are little things that I'll cry at
that might shock people yeah so read the
book now I gotta listen to the audio
version of course you can count on et to
bring you all the latest on Jes so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]